i completely forgot about tulsi gabbard  it's actually crazy how you know she was  polling one two three percent  there was a movement that was very  strongly behind her  um that wouldn't allow any criticism of  tulsi gabbard and said she is really the  progressive in all this different stuff  she clearly was not she just disappeared  left congress etc and then now all of a  sudden she's back and she's criticizing  joe biden and she's defending drones and  she's doing all sorts of very strange  things  i my advice is  just don't worry about tulsi gabbard uh  i i find her i couldn't find her less  relevant truly and it's crazy oh  actually someone even posted this to the  subreddit they said it's crazy because  biden is literally more progressive than  she is there's no question about it  there was nothing uh the the entire  tulsi thing was just a scam and i'm glad  that there are more people now  understanding  that they may have fallen for a scam